[Music]
hello and welcome
everyone good morning good afternoon
good evening wherever you are tuning in
from
we are so excited to welcome you to the
your journey
getting started panel and q a
my name is jessica chung i'm an
admissions
officer at the stanford graduate school
of business
and i'm really excited to kick off this
panel
and introduce you to our community and
to our
wonderful panelists today so just to
give you a bit of an
overview of today's event we're going to
start with a brief introduction
to our global community we're going to
have you meet our panelists we'll start
with a little bit
of um predetermined q a just to get the
panel warmed up and then we'll turn it
over to your questions and that's where
we're going to spend
most of our time today we are going to
spend
about 55 minutes together and we're so
excited that so many of you are spending
a part of your day with us
we've got a big crowd in the room which
is really really exciting
it might mean that we won't get to all
of your questions today
but i do encourage you to create an
account on
mystanford.mba or visit our website
where you can look at our many
many summer offerings to find events
that address your
additional interests i encourage you to
take a look and find the events that
address
all of your questions whatever we don't
answer today
and you can of course always contact our
office with your questions
my colleagues will drop our contact
information in the chat
we are 100 in your corner and we are
here to answer
all of your questions as you navigate
this process
um so i want to start by introducing you
all to our incredible community
spoiler alert every time i ask students
what their favorite part of the gsb is
they
i'd say 99 of the time say that the best
part of the gsb
is the people and the people
at the gsb come from all over the
country and all over the world they
represent
so many different backgrounds and so
many different interests
there's truly no single path to the gsb
and on this slide you can see a little
bit about
the many different perspectives that are
a part of our community
this is sort of our community by the
numbers but of course our our
community is so much more than these
numbers can really tell you
and so to that end we have an incredible
panel of students and alumni here with
us today
i'm going to let them introduce
themselves but as you can see on the
slide there's a little bit of
information about where
where they are coming from or where they
have gone after the gsb
so perhaps we'll start with let me see
and is andrew online yet
hi andrew do you want to start by
introducing yourself
perhaps including your class year where
you came to the gsb
from and where you are now
yeah absolutely happy to get us started
uh so andrew jakubowski a member of the
class of 2020 i
came to the gsb from mexico city
by way of brooklyn new york and
originally from philadelphia
and currently zooming in from mexico
city
so very glad to be here today and
looking forward to the conversation
awesome thank you for being here andrew
next up is
isabelle
hi everyone i'm isabel from quito
ecuador
before the gsb i was in ecuador working
in k-12 education
um and now i'm a second year mba
um thinking of working in workforce
development and i just wanted to say
that i will be smiling like stupid
because it's such an honor to be
with these folks in a panel
awesome thank you we i i feel honored to
be on a panel with you
too um jenny do you want to introduce
yourself
yeah happy too my name is jenny joe and
i am graduating along with issa this
june um and we're both pursuing in
addition to the gsb and masters in
education and before the gsb
i was working at bain in los angeles and
then after
school i will be returning to bain but
this time in the boston office
thank you so much for being here and
finally sam
you want to introduce yourself hi
i'm sam so good to see you jenny isabel
and andrew
um and you're right about the gsb um
being great for the people and it's just
so fun to see everyone on this panel
already
um i am sam i went to dartmouth
and um i was working in also in k-12
education but in the u.s
for the san francisco school district
right before the gsb i was a restorative
justice
i'm leadership coach um and i'm from
massachusetts i'm actually
home right now i'm living in new york
city though
and i'm a diversity and inclusion
consultant and trainer right now
i want to echo isabelle's excitement i
i so as one of the planners of this
event i brought together this panel
because
um these four have done some really
incredible things they've i think really
changed gsb's community and that's kind
of what we see our students doing not
only
does the gsb transform our students
and provide a transformative educational
experience our students in turn also
transform our community and i think
these four
incredible leaders have really done just
that
so i'll begin with a few questions and
then we'll turn it over to audience q
a so i'm first curious about why
why an mba and why a stanford mba what
was it that
drove you to pursue an mba and what was
it about stanford that drew you
to to campus whoever wants to start can
i can go get us break the ice
um because i only applied to stanford
um i only applied to one business school
i only wanted to go to stanford
um because of the focus on leadership
development
um and the qualitative side of of
running a business or running an
organization and the people the
importance of people
at my job at the san francisco school
district i was looking up at the
leadership and being like
there's a lot to work on here um i want
to work on these things and kind of
i saw some gaps in you know not not as
many
hard skill gaps more soft skill gaps um
and some hard skeletons i'm being honest
um
around scaling a really big program
around
um really disrupting a really entrenched
system
but also about re really about
leadership um and
i love that the gsb focused on that
um and i felt like they really had their
priorities right and like what
their area focus was i also was trying
to career
pivot not huge career pivot but away
from
directly in education and more towards
um just doing diversity and inclusion
for for anyone um and then
the biggest thing was talking to people
at the school
and hearing about the people and also
just like the really strong
community spirit of the gsb the living
on campus piece i think makes a really
big difference around that
um and it's just you know everyone's
we're all just
doing everything together and i loved
that about dartmouth
and i have lifelong friends from that
and now i feel like i have
like 800 lifelong friends at the gsb you
really do get to know everyone which i
think is really really special
um and pretty unique
i'm happy to answer and i'll sort of
take the two questions in turn
um first you know why an mba and then
second
you know what led me to stanford
specifically and
i had known for a while that i really
wanted to go back to graduate school
and for me there were two factors that
helped me land on an mba first i just
wanted what
i now frame as an enriching experience
so
personally enriching intellectually
enriching professionally enriching
and i think you can get that through a
lot of graduate programs
the second piece though is i wanted
something that would really
create possibility opportunity and
not limit in any way what the future
could look like
and i think that is where an mba is so
powerful in that it lets you
gain exposure test and learn but
it also is kind of infinitely open
in terms of what you do during and after
so i ultimately landed on pursuing the
mba
and stanford was um top of my list as
well
you know for three reasons you know
beyond the people which i think
people often um highlight you know just
first in terms of the curriculum
there's a level of openness in terms of
your mba courses but also the ability to
access
um classes you know how we say across
the street or in other schools
at the university and then within the
mba program
just academically in terms of research
there's a lot happening on
organizational behavior culture
diversity equity inclusion and these are
just
intellectual and academic areas that
really um
excite me the second thing was you know
stanford's proximity to
the startup world and to the social
innovation world and again
two areas that i have tangential
exposure to my pre-gsb
life but as a result feel a lot richer
and more informed as a result of
opting to go to stanford for the mba and
then finally you know the culture
i think really did um pop to me um when
i was kind of
weighing different options and in one
way because of
the curriculum because of the proximity
to what i identified there's
a slightly less stereotypical business
school type culture
which was really important for me and
you have that good old california
sunshine
um you know that vitamin d
boosting everyone's energy and
positivity so so that was just
a lot of my thinking and kind of the the
path from
what kind of school to which school and
um
you know where i am today
i resonate with things both sam and
andrew have shared
um i actually never even considered an
mba i did not
take the gmat um at the time i was
teaching at a really
radical public school in ecuador and
the only reason why stanford entered
into my
options was because i had a mentor which
just started an
ngo in the region um who had graduated
from the gsb
we challenged all these like stereotypes
about what a business school student
looks like
and what you can do with a business
school degree so he was living a very
scrappy life like just bringing students
from all across the continent together
and i found that really inspiring um so
i decided not to apply to harvard
divinity school which was
my choice my top choice and instead to
look at a degree that like anderson has
the opportunity to open many different
packs
and to also um offer more
security than i felt like i had was an
undergrad in philosophy so i'm very
grateful
that um that winter crossed my path
wow we're so glad you decided to apply
too that's awesome
like the hardest part about going last
is that i'm definitely not gonna
offer anything super novel but um
i come from a more traditional
background i'm not sure how many of you
on the webinar
come from finance and consulting and so
in many ways
i think the path that i was on from a
hard skills perspective i didn't
necessarily need
to come to business school and
definitely weighed the trade-offs
between you know
being able to make money and and have a
stable income for two years versus going
going potentially going into debt
um and i just want to kind of echo that
when i visited
i think i forget it was probably in the
fall i visited
a class where i witnessed a stanford
student essentially do a role play
in a way that i never thought that was
kind of possible
or was happening in business school um i
won't sort of go through the specifics
but essentially it was just really
highlighting that
what a leader looks like can and does
look like me and that there was a way
for my personality and my values to be
shown through my leadership
and i think for me drove home the point
that actually the next two years can be
an investment
in terms of like how to think about how
i want to be a leader and actually gain
a lot more reps and experience
and both in the classroom and i would
say outside the classroom as well i
think
one of the beautiful things about
business school and mba in particular
is that every you know coffee chat or
lunch or social event you go to is an
opportunity to
to meet people who are different from
you and then also you know learn where
your strengths are where your areas of
opportunity might be and it's been like
a continuous i think growing experience
for me as well to learn a little bit
more about myself and
also you know how i can contribute to
the broader world
so awesome thank you everyone
for those really really genuine
responses
i remember another student that i talked
to describe the gsb experience as
unlocking creative futures that it
really expanded sort of the
possibilities of what she could be and i
loved that
and i feel like all of your answers
reinforce
the possibilities and the the potential
of the business school experience
i'm going to ask one more question and
then i'm going to turn to our q a box so
for our attendees please keep submitting
your questions or upvoting other
attendees questions i already see that
there are so many really thoughtful
questions there so please keep
submitting your questions
or uploading the questions that you want
to see us answer
so my my last prepared question is what
was the best
application advice that you got our
attendees are
are starting their journey as an
applicant that's the theme of this panel
so what was one of the best
pieces of advice that you got about the
application process
or what advice do you wish you had
gotten
[Music]
i can kick myself on this one so my
advice has to do with
the what matters essay which hopefully
is still the essay and i'm not dating
myself
um i i think it is
really intimidating for that to be you
know an admissions question in some ways
because it doesn't
feel like the answer itself you know
should be super personal or should be
really authentic to you and i
you know have gone through the back and
forth process of like i think this is
what my answer should be
this is what people are telling me the
answer is and so i think my
my best advice in particular to the
stanford application is
but the admissions office really does
want to know what matters most to you
and why
um and the iterations of that essay that
i wrote that were
me trying to be someone that i thought
they wanted to admit
were never the best versions and i think
um i think one of the alums that i
talked to told me if you don't feel a
little bit vulnerable when you press
submit
you probably haven't done it fully um so
i would just encourage
all of you to really take some time to
introspect and think about the question
and don't be scared by the fact that you
know it just happens to sit on an
admissions
application because at the end of the
day i think no matter what happens it's
a very worthwhile
and fulfilling exercise and honestly
captures a lot of why stanford is
just such a special and unique place
because they really do want to get to
know you
i'm going to piggyback on on this um
i couldn't agree more jenny that is like
the number one thing
i highlight when i talk to friends who
want to apply to stanford is
i after meeting the people at stanford
i'm like
i think that is i mean i have no
evidence of this other than just who the
students are at stanford
but i personally think that is the key
thing to getting into stanford is
they're getting a lot of people
who are highly qualified in a lot of
different ways
and it's really like who you are as a
person and how you're able to convey
that through that essay
that i think is sets people apart and
like the more vulnerable
the more deep the more authentic raw and
real you can get
in that essay the better and one of the
things that i really recommend
is having a lot of different people look
at over
but people who offer different things so
like have a friend who went to business
school look at it
have a friend who's really good at
creative writing look at it have a
friend who knows you really well look at
it
and give you feedback from different
perspectives and make sure that it's
you know really well crafted and saying
what
really truly what you want to say and
it's authentically you
um i had my parents look at it and
people just people who
really really get me um and can like
hold me to
the authenticity bar of like is that
really what you're
uh what you want or what you know and
that forget the shoulds what i should be
like jenny said like
just be as much as you of who you are as
possible
um yeah i really think that like
spending a good chunk of time on that
is really really important
well i i think um both jenny and sam
really
spoke to the the what of the application
and i couldn't agree more right it's
about um just being your authentic self
and trusting yourself
and having that vulnerability and
willing to write what you truly want to
write
i think just the one ad that i would
make is
it's also about doing the how
authentically and so
um you know just the same suggestion of
testing with a lot of people
or getting a lot of input if that's your
best path forward for you as an
individual in this journey
lean into it right and take advantage of
the people around you
if that's not something that necessarily
resonates
then trust that instinct as well right
and i think you know
just to provide a bit of foil you know i
had a very
narrow um engagement with my application
and so
really i think if i've learned anything
along the way from peers
and folks that i've engaged with it's
there's a million ways to get to the
same outcome and it's doing
the path or the how that
really resonates and is authentic to you
the same way that the what
you know we hope is representative of
you in the application
[Music]
um i didn't have much
wisdom advice coming in but i think that
one of the ways in which i
won was that i didn't know at all about
all these websites and
forums where you can see when people got
calls and stuff like that
and one dinner i heard about all this
and i was like wow
like i had no idea i missed the call
saying i got into a do you because i
didn't even know i was gonna get a call
so like just taking distance from
all of the wealth of advice and people
making money
off of students that are interested in
joining business school
um i
can't speak for everyone but i think
that it really helped me to
not be constantly tied to
those systems and then the second part
is that
i know it's like easy for me to say from
this place but
your self-worth is not tied to where you
go to school
thank you all so much for those insights
so i'm going to turn to our
q a box now and i see we've got a lot of
questions coming in
so i'm going to suggest that for each
question
have a couple of you chime in and then
if anybody
else has something really really
pressing they want to add feel free to
chime in as well
but i'm hoping we can get through as
many questions as we can during this
time
so one question from shivam
that i really really like asks what is
one common misconception
of the gsb or perhaps put another way
which i think
um another student had asked what was
something that surprised you or that was
unexpected about your gsb
experience
well this feels relevant given the crew
um
i definitely came in thinking that
i had had my deep lessons on what
justice and ethical leadership looks
like outside of the gsb and that i was
just going to come in holding
tight to my values and not letting
anyone move me and
literally every single person on this
call has
helped me learn how to be a more ethical
leader and how to think
more complexly about issues of social
justice so like
i think there can be a narrow conception
of who goes to business school and
what drives them and i think there's a
diversity of people with many different
drives here
thank you for sharing that that's really
beautiful
i'm happy to jump in um
i guess i would say
i think people sometimes think that
business school is not hard academically
um and while
you know there is a kind of a buffer
with
the grades not really mattering
and i wouldn't say that it's necessarily
the academics that make it hard
the combination of all the different
things that
are happening at business school um
can be very uh can be a lot um
and i think it takes a bit of time to
figure out
how to manage everything even for people
who are very used to managing a lot of
different things
um and so i think fall quarter can be
quite overwhelming
just the pure number of classes
especially if you're someone who
is not familiar with you know the con
the business concepts i was coming from
education
meeting so many people all of whom are
so fascinating
all the different extracurricular stuff
all the different social events it can
be very
um it's amazing and like once you kind
of figure out your
what matters to you and why but once you
figure out
like what works for you um
it you can just get into flow really but
i do think it takes people some time
to manage everything because if you try
and do everything
a hundred percent you just you just
can't um
so i think coming in with like some
understanding of like it isn't all fun
and games like there is
like a lot to do and a lot to absorb
um and it can be hard at times like i
think i think a lot of my friends would
say like business school's like one of
the best experiences of their life but
it was also one of the hardest in a lot
of ways
and not and not just act like i wouldn't
say purely academically but just like
and
kind of figuring out who you are what
you want
what you want to prioritize who you want
to spend your time with
um it's an it's a new thing to go to
schools
as an adult um and i think just like
figuring that out
is is definitely a journey and i almost
feel like the gsp does it on purpose
because it's part of the learning
um but yeah that's one of the things i
would say
awesome thank you for that insight i i
have a
i have a follow-up question i mean i
think
i think graduate school business school
it's a transition for anyone whether
that's
whether that's a a transition in terms
of pace of life
a transition academically geographically
culturally
i think everybody experiences some kind
of some kind of transition
what were some of the best resources or
support systems that supported you all
in that transition
well i think um you know reflecting on
my
experience um it's definitely
the community and really just you know a
subset of
individuals who went
above and beyond to
i think demonstrate openness
empathy um unwavering support
um and i actually think this person
might even be joining this webinar right
now but you know it's
it's really the people who help with
that transition and i think
jessica you highlighted you know four or
five of
countless ways in which
the experience could be so different
from what you were living
previously that those transitions
mixed with everything sam highlighted
can create
a really acutely new
and challenging and
to sam's point it certainly forces
introspection learning growth
development
it's really hard to do that on your own
um
and so again i really think it's people
in the class people in the staff
professors to the extent you connect
with them
um resources outside the gsb but on
stanford's campus right and it's kind of
to like so much we spoke about you know
what resonates or meets your underlying
needs
you know what are your challenges and
how might the community be able to show
up to support there
yeah and i would add to what andrew said
there are so many
it's kind of a double-edged word i guess
there are so many clubs and communities
you could be a part of and they'll put
obviously a commitment onto your
calendar but it's the same
communities and groups that on days
where you're faced with
you know the plethora of challenges that
might arise throughout your day that
those are the people that you call you
texts you meet up with
um and i think after i was able to kind
of identify the communities and groups
that i wanted to invest in some of which
are related to social justice and impact
investing and things that i cared about
probably more on a professional level
but also things like my whim group and
my women in management group
that um issa is actually in and even
doing things like the gsb
show like i grew up dancing and dancing
has been one consistent thing that i've
continued to do and take a lot of peace
and joy
in um to keep to keep investing in them
because i do think like that's how
this experience really kind of shines in
the end is that you
have invested this time and energy with
people and they
reinvest it right back at you um and
then the only other thing i'll say is
don't forget about the people outside
this community who also want to and can
pour into you i feel like my first
quarter
my family barely heard from me and you
know when they did it was like are you
alive and i you know would take days to
respond because i was like inundated
with all of the excitement of the gsb
but especially as i'm looking to
graduation in a couple weeks like
i really really am pulling in um you
know my friends from every walk of life
um and sometimes wish i did that i did
that sooner in the experience because
they can serve as really important
reminders of
giving giving you perspective about this
experience and then also reminding you
of who you were before you came and who
you will be and continue to be
when you leave
thank you both for those responses so we
have a couple questions about
goals and i'm going to try to combine
them a little bit um
so hayden and adrian are wondering about
about what were what were your goals
when you were applying to the gsb
and if i can add um how might
how has the gsb changed your goals and
transformed your goals
in big ways and in small ways i will
also start by saying that
we admit students with sort of all
levels of clarity regarding their goals
whether they have a very very
exact and precise goal that they want to
achieve by the end of business school or
or through their business school
experience or if they have a more loose
undefined goal that they're interested
in so we admit students with
all across the spectrum in terms of
clarity around their goals
but our attendees are curious about what
some of your goals were coming in
and how the gsb has impacted your goals
whether it's made them more defined
whether it shifted them
what were some of your goals and how has
the gsb affected them
um at the start of the school year
kristen moss admissions director
does this speech where she calls on a
couple of folks
um actually like dozens of people and
she called on me being like and we have
a teacher from ecuador who's gonna
revolutionize education
in latin america or something like that
and i will not
revolutionize education in latin america
um i think that's
a goal that i still hold in some parts
of my heart but
i don't see myself in ecuador
in near future um and
it's been one professor i took a class
with jenny from
the dual degree program rob erstein
who's really pushed me to think about
um alternatives to higher education in
the us and how
the community college system is not
working very well and our apprenticeship
programs are not there yet and
um now that's an area that i've been
really excited about and trying to learn
as much as i can about how to connect
people to opportunities and it was all
very much tied to
to covet 19 and living over 19 at the
gsd and seeing max furloughs all around
and
trying to find how i can use my skills
to connect people to dignified work
um so goals have changed a lot
values have kind of stayed the same but
um
we'll see how they continue to change
in the coming months
i think issa's point or or suggestion
that
goals change with values stay the same
is a bit of
what my experience was so um when i
applied you know i somewhat naively
was thinking you know these are the
industries that are attractive to me
these are the functions that are
attractive to me
let me um put two and two together and
that's going to be my path forward
and you know i think my gsb
experience a combination of the the
academic coursework and the
extracurricular activities
i think just living through everything
we've kind of been talking about today
um forced if not
encouraged me to be a little bit more um
creative on how i'm thinking about you
know goals moving forward and so
what initially was that framework around
industries or functions became something
more
values based or i call them my pillars
in thinking about what opportunities may
look like moving forward and what
motivates me and what i would hope to
get out of a given opportunity
and so you know i think
very fortunately aspects of the the
program are intentionally designed
to help people broaden their way of
thinking about goals
um and simultaneously
define goals that again are authentic to
how they think and and what they aspire
to achieve and what they aspire to
impact in the communities around them
and so i think it's just this change
mental model in a way
um many of the same ingredients but
but now kind of recognizing that the
dish could take a lot of shapes
and taste delicious in the end
jessica can i add one thing it's not
what my goals were but
a friend who graduated from the gsb
wrote a blog post
it was actually an msx program and one
of i thought one of the really cool
things that he said that i think is so
true is that
while a lot of people at the gsb have a
lot of goals for themselves
when you go to events it often
people are often giving more than
they're taking at those events
and like offering advice offering
connections
offering help more than they're even
trying to meet their own
goals and i think that that's something
really special about the gsb
it doesn't feel like it's just a bunch
of people there to try and achieve their
goals even though people have
a lot of goals and it's like people are
there to achieve their goals but also
help other people achieve their goals
um and that's i think a really unique
and beautiful thing
about the gsb
thank you all so much for those insights
um i actually had a
related question that anna posted for
sam about pivoting
so anna asks or or says that they would
love to learn
more about how the gsb helped you pivot
um were there any specific courses or
campus activities that you found
particularly helpful
um so okay so the first thing that i
would say about this
is i think it's hard to underestimate
how much just
being within a culture
that has a language and learning that
language
matters like i now understand what
people are talking about
like when i went to business school my
friend my friends who worked
in the business like in the private
sector were like you need to stop saying
you want to work in business like that
doesn't mean anything
um and now i feel like i have a much
better just vocabulary and language and
understanding
that i can go into a conversation
um and and like understand what's
happening and also add value like people
like look to me now at having an mba
and add value in certain ways um so i
think that's actually just huge which is
just being like
inundated with um with
um conversation and then honestly i
think i learned as much about
the business world in my out of class
conversations and experiences
that as i did in class um
the second part of that was like and
what classes or what
um so i think what i would also say is
to push yourself like to take classes
that are not necessarily easy for you
and that are not playing to your
strengths as much as
and but have a different goal there
right like my goals in my
super quantitative classes were just
like i just need to understand this at a
basic level
i don't need to master it and i'm not
going to be going on to like
work in finance right i just want to be
able to understand what people are
talking about
um and and contribute or even know like
when i need help
um and then really dig in on the things
that i'm
passionate about and that i i'm i'm
good at um and also
and i really feel this is so important
understand that you as someone who
is coming from a unique background have
so much to add to the gsb
community and like i would talk about
teaching a lot
in my first year classes and people come
up to me and be like wow that was so
interesting to learn about how being a
teacher is like being a leader and how
that it was very similar like
and i just think they're
often people are like oh i feel like i'm
i'm an outsider like an impo
imposter surgeon but it's like no like
you were an attribute
to like you're um useful
for for other people to have that
outside perspective and to make sure
that you frame it in that way
um is really really important i can't
really stress that
enough i love that
thank you so much for that the next
question goes to
jenny and isabelle we had a couple
students asking or
a couple of prospective students asking
about your experiences pursuing
a joint degree so if you could share a
little bit about
what it's been like taking classes in
the two different schools
anything else about balancing those two
degrees
i think our attendees would really
appreciate it
i think the masters in education has
created an avenue for me to form
friendships with folks from different
programs
which has been so valuable uh from
lots of education students especially
the year before
coven this year the class is really
small but next year we'll be back again
um to i've taken a lot of d-school
classes where you get like
books from engineering and medicine um i
think that's the most valuable part
and then the second part is um i still
do love some philosophy
and i think the education school gives
me really helpful
theories and frameworks to which to
understand
um social processes and then the
business school and the design school
have like
lots of applied learning classes where
you can quickly learn like
the skills um which i could have easily
ended up in just a master's in education
program and i would have so
missed out on all of the like applied
learning
that the business school really excels
at
yeah i definitely echo a lot of
isabelle's um
sentiments because i actually think that
doing both at the same time has
bolstered
my experience um because i didn't i
didn't i never really thought that like
my mba experience in and of itself was
just going to be sort of applied to any
sort of business i was always sort of
more impact oriented but i didn't have a
ton of
exposure to the education world um
professionally before
coming to the gsb um so i would say two
things one is that to issa's point
like the community both sort of at in
the ed school but i would actually say
that the joint degree students has been
such a
such a really nice group of friends that
we formed over time
and i think moments where i felt a
little bit like
what about when we don't maximize profit
or what are the other values that matter
in this certain case i can always look
to my peers in the joint
degree program and know that i have a
home of people who are also sitting in
class
nodding along with me and so a lot of
those cross um
sort of cross-listed classes have been
really really helpful
um isa mentioned the disruptions in
education with professor erstein was
was really formative for me um and then
i think the second piece is
in some ways being a part of the ed
school has given me
um you know just a break from the gsb
sometimes honestly like sometimes it's
just nice to be able to bounce back and
forth
and you know meet people who have very
very different aspirations and career
trajectories than we
than we will um and it also serves as a
reminder that
successful and fulfilling careers look
very different for very different people
um and it's just nice to come into
contact and become friends with these
people
especially you know when you have two
years of being immersed in one and
sometimes also get an outlet in the
other so i feel very lucky to
to have done the joint degree
awesome thank you so much for sharing
those perspectives
the next question comes from nicole i
love this question
nicole asks who is the most inspiring
person you've met at stanford
and why seems like a really hard
question
too but i'm very curious about the
answer myself
um i'm gonna make andrew blush
um but andrew organized
the most beautiful display of allyship
i've seen
um it was this rally and support of
black classmates and
peers and professors and members of our
community at the height of
exactly one year ago um the height of
the black lives matter movement
and there was poetry and there were
singing and reached out to the dean to
make sure that
um we could have an in-person gathering
at a time when it wasn't allowed
and it was safe and it was really
inspiring so shout out to andrew
that was beautiful thank you for that
i know it must be a very difficult
question to answer
we can always come back to it um but as
a
isabelle thank you so much for sharing
that i think that that's really really
beautiful
and um one thing we used to say in our
presentations
is that the world needs
needs principled leaders now more than
ever
and i think that that's something that
is a big part of the stanford gsb
ethos and culture um
so it's i think it's really good to hear
that reinforced through the the actual
experiences that you all have had
on campus and in our community so thank
you so much for sharing that
um you can always come back to this
question i have
i have one that comes to mind um
maybe not what you were envisioning but
um
the gsb residences housing team and
is absolutely incredible and especially
as we transition into a totally virtual
experience
watching um arthel and his team just
essentially make things happen overnight
for us and keep us safe and to keep us
healthy and protected and just go above
and beyond
um he wins the distinguished service
award i feel like every five seconds so
probably knows this already but
just like the support team behind how
the gsb operates has been
so inspiring and sometimes i i just like
look look around and i'm like the reason
this looks the way it does and i can
just go about my day without having to
worry about
food or housing or you know whatever is
happening in the world or is because
there is like an army of people behind
the scenes who work so hard for us
um so i wanted to give them a shout out
awesome thank you for that so the next
question
comes from zach who asks could you talk
about your global experiences
and how you've applied those learnings
in your mba experience
so for those of you in the audience who
don't know we have a
global experience requirement as part of
the
mba education because we want our
students to
to learn more about how business happens
around the world
and to expand their global business
perspective
um maybe i'll throw this question to sam
and andrew just because i know things
have been
probably a little bit different during
the past year and some change
so sam andrew any any insights on the
global experience that you'd be able to
share
yeah i can go ahead and um i'll keep it
brief but i'd say a few things one
is a piece of advice and one is
so i did two global experiences i did a
gmx
um which is where you do an internship
in another country and i did a gst which
is like
the um what most people do
during their mba where they do like a
study trip
that's run by the second year students
in another country um
my gmix i so my internship at my gmax i
liked
even more than i liked my um regular
internship
um and doing it i was in paris working
at a tech company creating their l
d um their entire learning and
development curriculum
um and i just had i like talk given that
i was only there for a month i talk
about this experience
a disproportionate amount of time like
people probably think i lived in paris
for a year
um and like speak french which i don't
um but
i just had the best time
both like um professionally and
integrating into a whole another culture
and learning about how they work and
honestly
really vibed with it like they really i
think have a good
work-life balance um but also like
really
had a great business model um the tech
company that i was working at and it was
a gsb
founder and actually just seeing the gsp
leadership and he really was such an
epitome of a great gsb leader
embodied um in practice was so cool
um so i really just highly recommend the
gmix
experience um and i just think it was
such a unique
opportunity like when am i gonna get to
work in france it's like actually really
hard to get all the
um papers together to do something like
that um so this was a really
amazing opportunity for me um and what i
would recommend with the my piece of
advice
is i think that i focused too much on
the country like i
ended up in thailand on my gst and i
wish i'd focused more on the topic
um of the gst and been made sure that i
was passionate
passionate about the topic because
there's there's different topics
um for the different gsts and i
definitely was like oh i want to go to
thailand so that was the my decision
making process and i really do wish that
i had um
focus more not that it was great it was
really fun but i would say academically
i could have had a
more enriching experience and a more
unique experience
i think um than
than just focusing on the country so
that's a real
really if you end up going to just be a
real piece of advice i have and i really
wish i had been able to do
one of the global studies programs
before school started people really
loved those and came in with a very
strong group of friends
and i had a wedding so i couldn't do it
but it was um
something that i really feel like i i
wish i had been able to do so if you
have the opportunity to do that
um in addition to all the unofficial
events i think it really people
very much love those programs
yeah i i think just reflecting on my
experience um
so i grew up in a very uh
u.s americana type setting uh
in the philadelphia and suburbs
and i didn't leave the country until
after i had graduated from undergrad
but i did live abroad before going to
the gsb and it just
revolutionized so much about
the way i thought my values
how i defined success kind of all of
these factors that just made
having an international and
multicultural experience really
important for me and that was also a
contributing factor in kind of you know
business school and decisions made
while at the gsb i was just reflecting
now and realized
i did four global experiences
as well as um an internship
uh in brazil so in terms of
kind of the opportunities and
experiences afforded to me
you know i went to asia for the first
time
lived in europe for the first time i
traveled to and lived in brazil for the
first time
and accumulated professional experiences
in those settings
academic experiences in those settings
language culture and all of these other
aspects of being present that i just
wouldn't have necessarily had the
opportunity to pursue um if just one or
two factors were different
around you know my experience or or the
opportunities within the gsb
and so for those who who might be
outside of the us
and those who are interested in going
outside of the u.s perhaps after the
mba you know there's a lot of
possibility and opportunity
in what you can do to make that a
reality and
you know if you if that's what's
important to you
you know like some of the other things
we talked about you can really lean
in to um what's offered through the
program
um and you know i'm back abroad now and
i expect to stay abroad for a long time
um and in every place i go
right there's either a network or
perhaps an opportunity
or you know at least some type of
support that i think exists
and stems from the gsb community
awesome thank you so much so i know we
only have a couple minutes left i wish
i wish we could chat for much longer
you'll see that there's a poll
up please let us know how we're doing
we're here to serve you
so please let us know what we can do
better or what we're doing well
so i'll throw out two two more questions
it's very difficult because
our attendees have submitted some really
really amazing questions so i'm going to
throw out two
questions and you'll each have an
opportunity to respond
and you can pick which question you want
to respond to
so there have been a couple questions
about timing
a couple students have kind of been
wondering like how did you know that it
was the right time to get an mba if
or did you not know um so a question a
couple questions about timing
and then another question that i saw
asked if you could share your favorite
or most meaningful
class or experience that you've had so
those are the two questions you can pick
which one
you'd like to respond to and everybody
can can chime in
i'll just quickly say on timing you know
trust your your gut
there's no too early there's no too late
um
do it when it feels right um
and then if i can just speak to i think
two experiences that
i will carry with me um
i think for the rest of my life um we're
both
speaking um kind of larger scale
disclosure experiences and one was a low
keynote
um talking about diversity equity and
inclusion and my experience and
my identities and then the second was my
talk
which for those who aren't familiar is
just kind of a
tradition within the gsb community on a
weekly basis where two
individuals um really have
free white space to share
anything and everything they'd like and
i just
the the emotional um personal
communal aspects of both of those
experiences
will um stay with me i think forever
um adding to the timing question the one
mentor that convinced me to
um apply to stanford he told me i was
way too early and that i should wait a
couple of years before going to
business school i started at 23.
um my one of my closest friends here is
34.
so like you have the full range of like
10 years
of um difference in professional
experiences
i think it does shape how um
like sometimes the things that i'm
learning in class i haven't
seen an experience before and it's
harder to
realize like oh i i've seen this before
and this is how i could have done it
better
um and at the same time i think all the
classmates
have similar regrets but on another side
so i agree with andrew
that it's a personal decision
okay i can go um talking about the most
meaningful experiences are really
are because there were so many um
that what they were the things that were
the most meaningful experiences for me
and then i'll elaborate on one
were being the gsb show um like jenny
said um there's it was
on it's the last i was in the show that
was the last like real live show
um which hopefully we'll go back to that
soon um because there was
it was like one of the most incredible
personally fulfilling experiences of my
life um
doing like andrew said doing my talk i
think
was probably the most life-changing
thing i've ever done and i well i did
teach for america so maybe besides teach
for america
my talk was like the shortest
life-changing thing i've ever done
um because it's 30 minutes um
diversity committee which i know um was
meaningful to
to a lot of people and being able to
help
implement um real changes at the gsb
around diversity programming um
was i think it was the most like
um gratifying like part because i felt
like it was something i was giving
rather
than taking again going back to that
that theme
um and now i oh and and touchy feely
and you'll hear this a lot from a lot of
gsb students
um it's a class called interpersonal
dynamics and i feel like
it really i feel like so equipped to
deal with the world
now um and to deal with really difficult
situations
and experiences in a way that um
i didn't necessarily before and i feel
like i have a very
strong sense of who i am for the good
and for the bad
that nothing surprises me anymore um we
just did 360 reviews at work and i was
like yep i've heard all this before both
the good and the best like
nothing was i'm so used to giving and
receiving feedback
um and feel super comfortable with it i
guess i talked about all of them but
it's hard to
to dip in point one um
and yeah i i tell everyone i'm like
everyone do a talk like it really
is when in your life are you gonna have
time to just sit down and reflect on who
you are and what's made you you and then
have a whole group of people just listen
to you and only be focused on you
it was like the only time the dsp phones
were away like
people were laser focused on the person
speaking
um it was like it was like a sacred i'm
not a religious person but it was a
sacred time at the gsb
that was just so so special um and to be
a part of it
um and now i have this this video i get
to keep forever and like showing my kids
um it's just so so special
i know we have limited time just guess
i'll be short um
actually my experiences so they're
they're related to each other the timing
thing so ask someone who was going back
to the exact same thing i was doing
it's very easy to say that two years is
either investment
or potentially even you know i'm making
less than my peers
who stayed at the firm did um but i
think i am going back
a different a different kind of leader
and i was an arbuckle fellow so tied to
sam's experience of touchy-feely being
able to take that early
um in my mba one experience and just
really
understand like how i am landing on
other people um
and it actually inspired me to really go
back to bain because
i know that when i go back i can lead a
team pretty early on
and i will lead it in a completely
different way than i than i would have
two years ago and i have
the our book a leadership program to
thank for that um and the last thing
i'll make a plug for
is and me and a couple of classmates
organized this workshop
called dream big league bully for um
black college students
looking looking to develop their careers
not even into business school
and doing that one with some of my best
friends who i think we will forever
remember how we felt that day when we
put on a virtual event in the
height of covid but also acknowledging
that it was because we came to stanford
and had this network and had
all of these resources just thrown at us
that we were able to have the kind of
impact that we did
i think it served as like a really
really powerful reminder for me that
my education isn't just for me and it
isn't just
to develop my leadership and my career
and my skills all of which are true but
that this experience has given me a
platform and has given me a privilege to
really give back
um to people who may not have the same
sorts of access or opportunities so
i just wanted to put a quick plug even
though that's not technically a stanford
experience it definitely has defined a
lot of the way that i've seen the gsb
and just know that so many of our
classmates are going to go go back to
their communities and give back
in the same way
i love that thank you so much so that is
our program
for today thank you to our attendees for
spending a bit of your day with us and a
huge thank you
to our panelists thank you so much for
sharing your stories sharing your
experiences and your perspectives
i feel really grateful to have had this
opportunity to hear about
what your lives at the gsb and beyond
have been like
so i want to again say thank you and to
everybody
online take care and have a great rest
of your day
thanks everyone